rough day on Wall Street oil prices
plummeting stocks keep fallin as the
virus continues to spread there's a live
look at the Dow we were off more than
that earlier when I bring a David Asman
host of bulls and bears Fox Business
Network hello to you my friend yeah
we're only off 1800 points right now who
said something to me walking in studio a
hundred million Americans have some
portion of money invested in the market
it's called a defined contribution plan
most people know it as a 401k or an IRA
an individual retirement account more
money is actually an individual
retirement counts about 10 trillion
dollars in that versus about 5.9
trillion dollars in 401 KS but Americans
are invested in this economy and a lot
of them are worried about what's
happening with the stock market they
look at it right now tumbling by the way
this is an anniversary March 9 2009 11
years ago today was the beginning of the
bull market that was the low point
during the financial crisis we have come
up every year since this day today
ironically on the anniversary of the
bull market maybe the end of the bull
market we're only about 350 points away
right now if it continues to go down
from a 20 percent correction of the
market which is considered a beginning
of a bear market so a lot of people are
concerned but they shouldn't be taking
their money out of their accounts right
now if what they have is an IRA or a
401k and I'll tell you why because
basically it's the last bit of stuff
that you have in your retirement account
that you reach and time is your friend
if you're holding stocks over a long
period of time there's no other asset
that does better than the stock market
and considering that it's the last thing
you touch if you are retired if you're
already dipping into it it's too late if
you've got a few years before you begin
to dip in it leave it there leave it
untouched because over time it always
improves and I'm talking about a
five-year trend ten-year trend
definitely even a five-year trend is
your friend and it may well be that this
is only a six month or one year down
market if we enter into bear territory
because every time we've been through
one of these viruses before after six
months we come out the stock market is
ahead I think it's excellent advice
you're given here
you're basically saying don't panic well
don't absolutely.you don't panic the
it's a hard thing to do when you look at
this and you think about your retirement
money is in there just read we're
looking at your timeline the worst
mistakes invariably are made when people
do something with their market weather
where their stocks on the basis of a
panic buy or sell you don't you don't do
either thing if you feel panicky then
just turn off the channel and wait as
long as you can afford to wait for six
months to a year you'll be ok a couple
concerns here because you don't know
what happens with the virus maybe it's
bigger than we think maybe it's not that
that's one outstanding issue the other
is the world economy it's slowing down
you could probably forecast that and
what I saw from Israel last hour was
stunning to me they're saying that
anyone who travels into the country of
Israel will go into a 14 day quarantine
everyone if other countries start doing
that there is a pile-on effect of this
global economy going slower though the
question is how do you do business we
went through some of this after 9/11
when we realized that we weren't going
to be able to conference as much as we
can in person we had to do that's when
teleconferencing really took off like
wildfire now it's gonna be even more so
but there's a lot of stuff that you have
to be there for if if in fact we have
quarantines of factories of office
buildings even this office building who
knows we may be quarantine here I mean
what what happens to the way we do
business in America if in fact this
quarantine goes office wide and factory
wide and everything I don't think we're
going to go there but if that happens
it's our economy the world economy is
going to take a hit and remember the
Europeans were close to recession before
the virus chaos FairPoint much closer to
one I was telling the guys here in
studio I went to an NBA game at Madison
Square Garden and Friday night with
15,000 people and nothing happened hey I
just came back from Miami bill for my
anniversary at Miami the plane was full
nobody seemed to be particularly care in
fact I've heard that planes may be one
of the safest place because everybody is
washing down every engine on the plane
so nice to see a day but 50 minutes away
and thanks to see you David and welcome
back thank you so much that